Deutschland ein besetztes Land die
militärische Hoheit in diesem
Gesetz egal ob bei reichsbürgern
Germanys never been Severin again bei
gefallenen Schlagersängern deutschland
braucht endlich den Friedensvertrag oder
sogar beim russischen Präsidenten bis
heute besetzen sie Deutschland seit
Jahren tauchen solche Thesen immer
wieder auf
schwarz weiß rot und ein Friedensvertrag
und ein souveränes Deutschland wir sind
nicht frei wir sind immer noch ein
besetztes Land in Deutschland neigt
aktuell jeder vierte zu einer
verschwörungsmentalität das haben die
Autorinnen und Autoren der Leipziger
Autoritarismus Studie herausgefunden
aber mal im Ernst Deutschland einen
besetztes Land ferngesteuert von den
Alliierten das klingt doch ganz schön
absurd wir klären heute ein für alle mal
was an solchen Thesen dran ist und vor
allem was nicht
August 2020 Deutschland steckt mitten im
ersten Corona Jahr und in Berlin gibt es
solche Szenen Gegnerinnen und Gegner der
corona-maßnahmen demonstrieren im
Regierungsviertel viele friedlich aber
einige Treibens deutlich zu weit sie
durchbrechen die Absperrung des
Reichstagsgebäudes stehen auf dem
Treppen und schwenken schwarz-weiß-rote
fahren ihr Protest richtet sich nicht
nur gegen die Maßnahmen mit der Aktion
wollen sie vor allem eins deutlich
machen Deutschland die Bundesrepublik
ist in ihren Augen kein souveräner Staat
in der Logik der fadenträger existiert
nach wie vor das Deutsche Reich aber wie
kommen die darauf was soll das heißen
kein souveräner Staat dafür müssen wir
kurz ausholen Achtung kleine
Geschichtsstunde das Deutsche Reich
1871 Preußen gewinnt in Deutschland
Krieg es entsteht das deutsche
Kaiserreich das zerfällt mit dem Ende
des Ersten Weltkriegs für etwas mehr als
100 planen und wird von der Weimarer
Republik abgelöst der Name des Staats
Deutsches Reich bleibt bestehen 1933
kommt dann eher hier an die Macht Adolf
Hitler und ersetzt die erste richtige
Demokratie durch seine faschistische
Diktatur Stichwort Ermächtigungsgesetz
ab jetzt existiert das Dritte Reich bis
die Wehrmacht am 8 mai 1945 kapituliert
und die Alliierten Deutschland unter
sich aufteilen und daraus entstehen 1949
die Bundesrepublik und die DDR soweit
die Basics und trotzdem glauben manche
Deutschland sei heute immer noch besetzt
egal ob im August 2020 vor dem Reichstag
oder wenn Reichsbürger den Umsturz
planen aber was genau sind denn jetzt
deren Argumente schauen wir uns die mal
genauer an Thesen Nummer 1 Deutschland
war nie souveränen der Beweis dass
Besatzungsstatut vom 21 September 1949
klar da kann man schon mal aufhorchen
kommen weil dieses besatzungsstadt Tut
genau an dem Tag in Kraft getreten ist
nachdem die erste frei gewählte
Regierung der Bundesrepublik vereidigt
wurde nachdem nämlich am 23 mai 49 das
Grundgesetz verabschiedet wurde fand im
August die erste Bundestagswahl in den
bisherigen drei west-zonen statt die
Union gewann die Wahl und einen Monat
später wurde Konrad Adenauer der erste
deutsche Kanzler und direkt an seinem
ersten Tag hatte der mit seiner
Regierung gleich einen entscheidenden
Termin und zwar im Siebengebirge gar
nicht weit weg von seinem Regierungssitz
in Bonn nämlich bei der sogenannten
Alliierten hohenkommission die wurde
geleitet genau von drei hohen
Kommissaren einer aus England einer aus
Frankreich und einer aus den USA und ja
auch das ist richtig mit dem
Besatzungsstatut haben die sich
unglaublich viel Einfluss gesichert und
der Regierung von Konrad Adenauer ganz
schön wenig Spielraum gelassen die hohe
Kommission hatte z.B in der Außenpolitik
weiterhin den gut auf und volle
Kontrolle über die Genehmigung von neuen
Gesetzen Deutschland wurde also
tatsächlich faktisch weiterhin von den
Alliierten kontrolliert der Punkt ist
aber das war alles genauso geplant im
Besatzungsstatut steht nämlich auch das
hier drin nach zwölf Monaten mindestens
aber innerhalb von 18 Monaten nach
Inkrafttreten dieses Statuts werden die
Besatzungsmächte eine Überprüfung seiner
Bestimmungen vornehmen mit dem Ziel die
Zuständigkeit der deutschen Behörden auf
den Gebieten der Gesetzgebung Verwaltung
und Rechtssprechung zu erweitern die
Alliierten hatten zwar die Kontrolle es
war aber auch von Anfang an geplant die
mit der Zeit abzugeben nämlich dann wenn
sich die Demokratie in der
Bundesrepublik stabilisiert hat und
jetzt kommt genau das ist passiert in
den Jahren danach wurde das
Besatzungsstatut mehrfach und ganz
planmäßig modifiziert und dann sogar
endgültig ersetzt und zwar am 5 mai 1955
mit den sogenannten Pariser Verträgen da
stand direkt am Anfang dieser extrem
wichtige Satz die Bundesrepublik hat
volle Macht über ihre inneren und
äußeren Angelegenheiten tada plötzlich
war die Bundesrepublik unabhängig die
Alliierten haben sich zwar noch das
Recht gesichert im Notstand wieder
einzugreifen das Besatzungsstatut war
damit aber wortwörtlich Geschichte wir
können also festhalten ja Deutschland
war tatsächlich noch fest in der Hand
der Alliierten und ja auch das
Besatzungsstatut hat es gegeben mit den
Pariser Verträgen wurde das aber
abgeschafft und Deutschland wurde
politisch souverän Teese Nummer 1 Check
widerlegt aber tatsächlich gibt es ja
noch ein Haken die Alliierten hatten ja
immer noch das Recht in Notfall wieder
einzugreifen was wurde denn daraus hier
kommt die nächste hartnäckige these ins
Spiel die Sache mit dem Friedensvertrag
davon habt ihr wahrscheinlich alle schon
mal gehört der Mythos scheint einem aus
jeder Ecke entgegen wie steht es zum
Beispiel so schön auf der Homepage eines
baden-württembergischen afd-politikers
von nunmehr 75 Jahren gegen der Krieg zu
Ende und noch immer hat Deutschland
keinen Friedensvertrag ist Deutschland
also genau genommen immer noch im Krieg
oder immer noch in den Händen der
Alliierten Antworten darauf hat er
Wissenschaftliche Dienst des Deutschen
Bundestages und der kommt zu diesem
eindeutigen Ergebnis unmittelbar nach
Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges wurde kein
Friedensvertrag mit Deutschland
abgeschlossen moment mal bedeutet das
etwa Deutschland ist tatsächlich noch im
Krieg um es direkt zu sagen nein
natürlich nicht trotzdem stimmt was der
wissenschaftliche Dienste schreibt er
nimmt es halt ganz genau unmittelbar
nach Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges wurde
kein Friedensvertrag mit Deutschland
geschlossen das Problem war nämlich so
skurrile klingt ist gab nach dem Ende
des Zweiten Weltkriegs einfach keine
Regierung in Deutschland die so einen
Vertrag hätte abschließen können
stattdessen haben die Alliierten eine
andere Lösung gefunden Anfang der 70er
Jahre haben sie einfach einseitig ihre
Friedensabsichten gegenüber Deutschland
erklärt damit war die Sache erstmal
durch und kam erst viele Jahre später
wieder auf den Tisch und zwar mit der
Wiedervereinigung und dem sogenannten
2+4 Vertrag den schließen die Alliierten
mit der DDR und der Bundesrepublik im
September 1990 in dem Bewusstsein dass
ihre Völker seit 1945 miteinander in
Frieden leben also Frieden und dem 2+4
Vertrag steht auch drin das vereinte
Deutschland wird die Gebiete der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der Deutschen
Demokratischen Republik und ganz Berlins
umfassen seine Außengrenzen werden die
Grenzen der Deutschen Demokratischen
Republik und der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland sein und werden am Tage des
in Kraft Tretens dieses Vertrags
endgültig sein damit können wir endlich
auch das andere große Rätsel lösen das
mit der Souveränität und dem
Notstandsrecht mit dem 2 + 4 Vertrag
wurde Deutschland nämlich nicht nur
wieder vereinigt sondern nach der
jahrelangen polit Menschen Souveränität
auch endlich juristisch souverän und
damit wäre auch der allerletzte Zweifel
ausgeräumt Deutschland ist kein
besetztes Land damit können wir direkt
zwei große Mythen ein für alle Mal
widerlegen der 2+4 Vertrag von 1990
ersetzt den fehlenden Friedensvertrag
und Deutschland ist seitdem ein
souveräner Staat und längst nicht mehr
von den Alliierten kontrolliert über
eine Sache müssen wir aber noch reden
die wird nämlich oft benutzt und zu
argumentieren dass Deutschland trotz
allem kein freies Land sein das
Grundgesetz ist keine Verfassung sondern
ein Provisorium schreibt z.B der
ehemalige Radiomoderator Ken Jepsen in
seinem telegram Kanal die These ist in
verschwörerischen Kreisen aus
verschiedenen Gründen sehr weit
verbreitet und wird sogar verwendet um
zu argumentieren warum die
Bundesrepublik selbst gar nicht wirklich
existiert das Gute zuerst doch die
Bundesrepublik existiert und wir haben
sogar eine Verfassung die heißt noch
nicht so hat aber die gleiche Gültigkeit
und Norwegen des sogenannten
parlamentarischen Rats der hat 1948
seine Arbeit aufgenommen und bestand aus
65 Abgeordneten die kamen aus den elf
westdeutschen Landtagen und die haben
gemeinsam an einem Dokument gearbeitet
dass die Voraussetzung für einen neuen
Staat schaffen sollte bis heute trägt
das seinen Namen das Grundgesetz
1949 ist es in Kraft getreten nachdem es
vom Parlamentarischen Rat den Alliierten
und den Landtagen bestätigt wurde
seitdem hat die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland eine Verfassung und trotzdem
sind da manche anderer Meinung und das
liegt vor allem an zwei Passagen
Passagen Nummer 1 der alte Artikel 23 da
standen nämlich das hier drin und zwar
dass das Grundgesetz zunächst in allen
bestehenden Bundesländern gilt und das
ist in anderen Teilen Deutschlands nach
deren Beitritt in Kraft zu setzen ist
ein ziemlich entscheidender Artikel vor
allem für die Wiedervereinigung nach
1990 war der Artikel aber überflüssig
und wurde ersetzt gut für die
Bundesrepublik aber auch eine
Steilvorlage und zwar für alle die die
Unabhängigkeit der BRD bezweifeln die
argumentieren nämlich dadurch dass der
alte Artikel 23 gestrichen wurde wurde
auch der Teil gestrichen in dem steht wo
das Grundgesetz überhaupt gilt nämlich
in den aufgezählten Gebieten Deutschland
hätte also in der Konsequenz gar kein
definiertes Staatsgebiet mehr und
existiere also gar nicht mehr der Punkt
ist diese Schlussfolgerung ist doppelt
falsch im Grundgesetz ist sehr wohl
definiert wo es gilt und zwar in zwei
Stellen werfen wir doch mal einen Blick
rein also Grundgesetz für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
eingangsformel hier steht das in allen
deutschen Bundesländern die Einheit
vollendet wurde und damit gilt dort das
Grundgesetz na also direkt am Anfang für
das gesamte deutsche Volk in seinen 16
Bundesländern und weiter geht's ein
bisschen weiter hinten Artikel 79 Absatz
3 eine Änderung dieses Grundgesetzes
durch welche die Gliederung des Bundes
in Länder die grundsätzliche Mitwirkung
der Länder bei der Gesetzgebung oder die
in den Artikeln 1 und 20 niedergelegten
Grundsätze berührt werden ist unzulässig
die berühmte Ewigkeitsklausel sozusagen
das aß im Ärmel wenn es um die Existenz
Deutschlands geht Deutschland hat also
ein definiertes Staatsgebiet und in dem
gilt auch das Grundgesetz und warum
genau soll Deutschland jetzt nicht frei
sein denn Jepsen das Grundgesetz ist
keine Verfassung sondern ein Provisorium
dieses wird insbesondere im Artikel 146
deutlich der berüchtigte Artikel 146 der
allerletzte im Grundgesetz da wird
tatsächlich noch mal knifflig da steht
nämlich dieses Grundgesetz das nach
Vollendung der Einheit und Freiheit
Deutschlands für das gesamte deutsche
Volk gilt verliert seine Gültigkeit an
dem Tage an dem eine Verfassung in Kraft
tritt die von dem deutschen Volker in
freier Entscheidung beschlossen worden
ist ist das Grundgesetz also tatsächlich
keine Verfassung sondern nur Provisorium
und heißt es auch wir sind erst dann
frei wenn wir uns eine eigene Verfassung
gegeben haben keine Panik natürlich
nicht klar es gilt was im Artikel 146
steht theoretisch kann das Grundgesetz
jederzeit ersetzt werden trotzdem heißt
das nicht dass das Grundgesetz keine
Verfassung ist Artikel 146 Grundgesetz
räumt vielmehr die Möglichkeit ein dass
das Grundgesetz von einer anderen
Verfassung abgelöst werden kann ok und
warum heißt das Ding denn nicht einfach
Verfassung ganz einfach weil der Name
nie verändert wurde ursprünglich war das
Grundgesetz tatsächlich nur so lange
gedacht bis Deutschland wieder vereinigt
ist als Provisorium bis es dann dazu kam
hatte sich das Grundgesetz aber bewährt
und der Name bliebt der gleiche das
bedeutet aber auch Deutschland ist ein
freies Land mit einer eigenen Verfassung
dem Grundgesetz wir können also
festhalten diese Nummer drei Check
widerlegt fassen wir mal schnell
zusammen auch wenn es viele behaupten
Deutschland ist natürlich nicht mehr
besetzt die das Republik ist politisch
und juristisch unabhängig ein
demokratischer Staat und ja sie hat
sogar eine eigene Verfassung und ja
natürlich ist Deutschland mit den
sogenannten Alliierten des Zweiten
Weltkriegs eng verbunden und in
bestimmten Bereichen auch stark abhängig
Stichwort Außenhandel oder Sicherheit
trotzdem bedeutet das noch lange nicht
dass die USA oder irgendein anderer
alliierter Deutschland kontrolliert oder
gab besetzt hat auch wenn manche Stimmen
das immer wieder behaupten was denkt ihr
denn darüber hattet ihr schon
Berührungspunkte mit solchen falschen
Informationen und wie geht ihr damit um
schreibt mal in die Kommentare